[Musique]
voilà vous fait découvrir les grands
textes propos recueillis par isabelle
beige clair et alexis jacquet ce que je
pose pour vous poser une question dont
je sais d'avancé qu'elle vous agace
prodigieusement
est ce que vous êtes hypermnésique vous
lisez la fontaine vous lisez philippe le
ray vous lisez ces lignes vous lisez
hugo baudelaire
vous revenez sur scène régulièrement
pour les relire
est-ce que vous avez une extra mémoire
question accablante habituellement c'est
bien ce que ce geste de la fin d'études
à vie mais qui veut faire le contact
avec pujadas vous êtes espagnol aussi
dans le film
et comme les femmes du 6e étage 12e
étage un million et demi c'était un
miracle
alors évidemment quand vous faites une
représentation deux heures où vous avez
essayé le plus possible de ne pas trahir
l'altitude la puissance la beauté du
langage et quelqu'un vous dit rob [ __ ]
qu'est mémoire tu as l'impression que
c'est pas ça le plus important parce
qu'on peut imaginer des acteurs avec
beaucoup de mémoire qui soit très rasoir
mais je vous assure qu'on se pose la
question et c'est la passion c'est
connaissait un nombre tellement
important de textes et mécénat lise et
non cessibles c'est un mot qu'on
galvaude beaucoup c'est d'être conscient
de la supériorité de la langue française
pas par rapport à une autre langue mais
simplement l'aimé tellement fort l'aimé
tellement fort comme disait ce qui rend
le drame des français c'est qu'ils n'ont
même plus la passion de leur langue
cette langue est tellement somptueuse
tellement riche tellement pas solennelle
tellement pas prétentieuse aller
tellement et la fontaine en est
tellement l'incarnation que trente ans
de sa vie a été au service de ça je ne
peux pas ne pas vous demander de faire
un extrait du corbeau et du renard en
verlan
c'est un morceau de choix du spectacle
mais il connaît ça peut être mais beau
corps c'est la seule que je transgresse
à tout le reste est totalement tout le
spectacle et est totalement classique le
très beau corps sur abreu haché père
david mettait dans son look d un match
trop autres ménard par l'odeur alléché
il tente à peu près ce langage là et
jambon fumeurs du beau court que vous
êtes tous les jours que vous me blessant
lui même sentir mans c'est votre match
remporté 4 pages plus vous êtes le next
et des portes ces lois même le beau
corps à ces mots ne se sent pas de
voyage
et pour traitement ça le bâlois vrai ou
un jeune charles b les sauts tiens on
dirait que je parle très très
sérieusement aux français très moi je la
relève et laisse béton la loi prenne le
narrosse faut que je vous aime beaucoup
d'avis parce que c'est une petite fable
au milieu des chefs-d'oeuvre un mot
avant de vous dire au revoir
c'est une phrase merveilleuse aller de
la fontaine elle dure 30 secondes et
elle nous associe aux femmes du 6e étage
se croire un personnage efforts communs
en france disait la fontaine pour vous
dire qu'il faut pas voir un gros ego on
se fait l'homme d'importance il on est
souvent qu'à bourgeois c'est proprement
le mal françois l'asean vanité nous est
particulière les espagnols sont vains
mais d'une autre manière leur orgueil me
semble en un mot beaucoup plus fous mais
pas si sow est ce que vous avez vu
comment que je communique aussi sur le
triomphe des femmes du 6è il ya du
boulot et je suis très heureux d'avoir
été reçu par vous j'apprécie mais j'ai
une dernière question à vous poser j'ai
entendu que vous disiez que vous alliez
prendre votre retraite
alors ça on n'imagine pas ça vous est un
hyperactif vous êtes partout vous
démultiplier c'est vrai c'est un
fantasme de 2 c'est un fantasme d'être
capable de passes aveugles et dans
l'action et de pouvoir être capable de
d'être dans la métaphysique de
l'existence mais c'est un peu c'est un
peu ma forte à la race
merci fabrice luchini d'abord il est bon
mais aussi je remercie france 2 les
chais du 6e étage un million et demi on
n'avait pas encore dit donc je pense
qu'il remercie david et bien sûr l'homme
qui fait aimer la fontaine
[Musique]